good afternoon everyone welcome to this
meeting of cabinet and first off first
item on the agenda apologies for absence
Thank You Caroline disclosures of
interest do we have any disclosures of
interest no minute some of the meeting
held on the 25th of 26th of November and
15th of December agreed minutes are
agreed
thank you before we move on to the rest
of the items on the agenda there's some
issues arising out of the West Midlands
combined Authority meeting I went to on
Friday notably the ones that affect I
said back off for a minute at a meeting
on Friday an industrial strategy player
wind and an energy strategy paper went
in the energy strategy paper one of the
things that is of particular interest to
us in this district is the electricity
supply which we suffer grid constraints
that could well actually limit growth
plans in the district I raised this
issue both in the pre-made and the West
Midlands combined Authority meeting and
as a result it should be given a much
higher priority because this is an issue
where the weight of the combined
Authority with central government is
much greater than either the weight
we've got or the way that counties got
the other item that was of interest is
an item that was there about refreshing
our approach to culture which actually
means the West Midlands combined
Authority are giving the whole culture
and tourism agenda much more
significance and we play you know quite
a part in the various committees and
group
that look at that Isabel our head of
paid service he's actually on one of the
groups so that's really important to us
and we intend playing a very full role
in that arena and the final thing is
following all the bid to the left we
actually convened a stakeholder event in
November in the district to gauge the
appetite of key partners to work
together on the coherent vision for
stratford-upon-avon town a lot of people
attended there the key stakeholders the
strong support amongst the partners and
stakeholders to pull our collective
efforts together in shaping
stratford-upon-avon making sure we
remain a global destination protecting
our heritage and creating a vital
vibrant economic offering to the public
obviously this dovetails in exactly what
I was saying previously there's a second
session arranged for the end of January
to better define the scope and vision of
the master plan brief we will carry on
doing that because it is really
important that we feed this in both to
probably what it should let and the West
Midlands combined Authority because
increasingly that is where an awful lot
of funding and influence is available so
we do really do not want to miss out on
any opportunities so with that
moving on to matters to be referred to
the council the first item is item four
notice emotion peony pavilion and I
believe we have people in the audience
who wish to speak we have mr. Curtis and
mr. Baxter and a Miss Savage do you want
to come up to the table please and use
the microphone there will be fine
you have five minutes whenever you're
ready
and please remember to use the
microphone if you would know five
minutes in total I've been elected to
speak for all the residents for the
residents good afternoon and thank you
for giving me the opportunity to raise
residents concerns in relation to the
proposed sighting of the peony pavilion
in the firs I'm David Curtis and I live
on leaves in place about a minutes walk
from the firs for 18 years and mr.
savage lives on Grove Road directly
opposite the site Council accepted this
generous and prestigious gift and we
agree that it should be sited in a
high-profile and accessible location
however we don't believe the Furze meet
these criteria and that siting the
pavilion here will have a detrimental
impact on this important public space
the people who use it and nearby
residents statements from members about
potential benefits of the pavilion
highlight its tourism potential and
opportunities to cement relationships
with China both are important and both
require the Pavilion to be sited where
it is highly visible and easily visited
the firs is a small community asset it
is not at a gateway to the town nor a
tourist area but in a residential
neighborhood bordered on all sides by
busy roads with double yellow lines
parking is within the residents parking
scheme and under considerable pressure
at one end is the police station I saw
and the other the accident hotspot of
the town's most problematic road
junction there is no pedestrian crossing
to the firs Holloway's Authority express
concerns about distraction to traffic
posed by the pavilion and potential
increase in accidents
to address this they asked that the
pavilion be screened so it cannot be
seen from the road and the pedestrian
access at this end of the park is
blocked off for much of the day Grove
Road which runs along one side has stand
still traffic this is not a prominent
and high-profile site officer
suggestions that it would be suitable
for quiet contemplation all performances
are frankly absurd the pavilion will not
be visible hazard a visit or hazardous
to visit on foot and impossible to park
nearby if it cannot easily be visited by
pedestrians and there is no parking it
is simply unsuitable as a kept vacation
to achieve the council's aims no matter
how Lord of all secondly the impact on
the Third's would be significant the
scale of the pavilion a two-story
building is out of proportion to the
space and its design incongruous with in
a conservation area
the first was also a gift an important
open space enjoyed by many but this
proposal would greatly reduce the usable
area residents used to walking through
the park would simply cross at the
shortest point the Opera cultural
assessment suggests mature trees would
be damaged while its character would be
changed by the repose 10 foot high
screen council proposals should design
out crime some councillors may recall
the first history of anti-social
behavior drug and alcohol abuse
thanks to repeated campaigning by
residents that this was finally
addressed and an alcohol restriction
placed on-site it would be a great pity
for council to undo residents hard work
to make the furs more welcoming by
creating a criminal cul-de-sac by
closing off access creating a 10 foot
high screen and providing a structure
effectively a shelter for anti-social
activity making it less attractive for
residents and visitors creating a cycle
of anti-social behavior and decreasing
use of this community resource with
rising rough sleeping and begging in the
town cabinet may ask where the views of
the police
have been taken into account in this
consultation process we're confident
cabinet believes Council wishes to
achieve best practice but have concerns
there was no public consultation prior
to planning process
officers replies the residence inquiries
were unhelpful and obfuscator e
information about the project may have
met minimum statutory requirements but
not best practice officers knowingly
gave false information to councillors in
the recent planning meeting 47
objections from the local residents
appear to count for the chairman of the
Planning Committee said the views of
highways a statutory council T could be
ignored citing the pavilion in the firs
cannot achieve the outcomes you wish for
and what donors would expect so we
believe other options should be properly
explored thank you for your time right
are there any questions for the
residence thank you I'm just obviously
you've suggested that the first isn't a
suitable location what locations have
you arrived at that well I don't believe
it's I don't believe it's my job to
actually identify other locations but I
think the Bancroft or the high ground
behind the brass rubbing Center both
offer closer links to Shakespeare and
Tang Jing Zhu and Stratford and Fugees I
think there are certainly other areas
that could well be looked at that would
provide the venue or a site of the right
profile I have been to China on at least
a dozen occasions and I'm fully aware of
the importance of both giving and
accepting gifts
and I do believe this is a as with many
residence we believe this is a very
important and prestigious gift and does
need to be cited in the right place in
which case thank you very much thank you
thank you the notice of motion actually
is to request cabinet to examine
possible alternative sites for the gift
of the peony pavilion and that review
has already taken place and included
looking at locations within the
ownership of the council which included
traffic islands Knights Lane at sitting
ttan the Warwick Road lands the
recreation ground the Bancroft gardens
the pedestrian splinter island at Bridge
way land in front of the Crown Plaza the
Welcome Hills and the first Gardens
there are flood zones for example the
recreation ground the Bancroft gardens
Warwick Road lands land in front of the
Crown Plaza
these would require Environment Agency
approval which couldn't be guaranteed
and in addition the flooding would
damage the timber structure of the
pavilion traffic islands would not allow
the pavilion to be fully used and
highway safety could be an issue and
Knights lane and welcome Hills are too
far from the town the first garden there
for which is low-key located on the
prominent entrance to the town and it
has the garden setting which allows the
correct setting for the pavilion hence
being the preferred location thank you
here
any further discussion the ward members
wish to speak all right councillor
Anjali remember that first of all I'd
like to thank the leader for allowing
residents to speak there was some
difficulty there but thank you very much
I think was the right thing to do mr.
Casas mr. savage mr. Baxter have set out
residents concerns may I summarize
concerns and add a little dangerous
Junction were many we were there many
reported accidents in fact the last five
years have been five at two serious
accidents and eight accidents slightly
less but of sufficient seriousness it
took to be reported and I understand
from residents there are shut there are
shots and and near misses every day in
fact I had been party to one or two on
my bicycle
the County had this junction high on
their lists the work to be done to make
it safer cannot he at first objected
because of the dangerous nature of the
junction and their mitigation was to
place the pavilion away from the Apax as
I understand and further into the body
of the park but offer meeting here in
November they removed their objection
providing the entrance opposite chestnut
work walk was removed and planting took
place to to screen the pavilion from the
traffic coming into town there G
mitigations which will make the siting
of the pavilion more problematic
visitors walking to Anne Hathaway's
cottage will arrive at the double
crossing to gain access to shortly field
and beyond and seeing the pavilion will
want to go and see it naturally but
there is no will they climb over the
wall if that engine sees is closed off
and there are no pedestrian crossings
screening how tall six meters defeats
the ambition of this council
this gift and reflecting the leaders
reasons for citing it here spoken at the
recent planning committee with which I
completely agree but those are reasons
to accept this gift to the town because
it will actually help the time but this
as I actually think on planning reasons
is a problematic place to put it
please note there are no photographic
opportunities from coaches which given
the nature of some of the tourists
visiting here will actually people will
want to do and there was no closed coach
park nearby for a coach to party to walk
to see it screening also factors in
antisocial behavior as we've actually
heard and that's contrary to the
neighborhood plan development policy be4
as we know this is the first garden is
subject from time to time to anti-social
behavior and screening will only
encourage it and it also defeats the
aspirations of the purpose of this gift
I find it hard to understand how we've
come to this sorry situation we really
shouldn't be here I understand the gift
was accepted sometime last year well I
don't quite understand why when we
haven't celebrated this gift before
perhaps with a small exhibition at
Elizabeth passed with pictures of the
pavilion and maps of places with
residents views could have been
expressed but don't understand why there
was no pre application to district
counselors about this this the planning
application has left very little time to
address the issues that have been raised
and seek a more prestigious site with
easy access and good visibility there
are other issues that the residents are
very concerned about namely the lack of
Trance
transparency in the consultation process
and they're asking why this application
has been handled so in sensitively
overall I'm very very sorry I'm having
to say this at this meeting but I do
feel it's not being well handled and I
hope that we can actually
date find a satisfactory solution to the
problem we have in front of us
Thank You counselor fragile e I do note
with some considerable interest that the
town council planning consultative
committee made no representations on
this particular planning application and
as I am a member of the planning
consultative committee as are you
I am extremely well aware that any
councillor can actually ask for the
planning a planning application to go to
the planning consultative committee that
was not the case on this particular
issue because I'm not here to speak on
behalf of the town council you could
have raised it and actually at this
point in time this issue is far beyond
what the time might have said whether
they approved of it disapprove of it or
gave no representation we are beyond
that coming into a situation that needs
to be resolved
nevertheless councilor family it is
exceedingly interesting that there were
no representations from the Town Council
I don't argument but we are where we are
can we move on and can we find a proper
solution to this difficult situation
councilor Pemberton Thank You chairman I
think first I think I will I have to
correct a statement made by councilor
fragile e in relation to the county
council's response to this matter the
county council's initial response was
not to raise an objection and my
understanding is that following
interventions or representations would
be a more appropriate phrase by the ward
member which which there which the ward
member is legitimately entitled to do
following representations by the ward
member the County Council then raised
some objections so it is not true to say
that the County Council objected at
first instance that was not their
position it is true to
that the County Council then engaged
with the applicant as is right and
proper in every single planning
application of every different type that
applicants will engage with the local
planning authority and with statutory
council twos to ensure that wherever
possible barriers to development are
removed because as the board member will
be keenly aware there is a presumption
towards development enshrined in our
planning law and regulation and in the
national policy planning framework in
terms of the consultation the
consultation that was undertaken by the
applicant was the cook met all the
requirements of consultation there was
no lack of transparency an application
was laid before the statutory Council to
they were invited to make their
representations the appropriate notices
were put up and officers also provided
information to local residents by
writing to them I note as I was at I
note as I was at the Planning Committee
that that is disputed by certain people
who were in the audience that night and
are in the audience today I also note
and I am now going to make a comment on
it that there's been an allegation of
willful and active misleading of members
of the committee by officers in this of
this council and as the planning policy
portfolio holder I have to say I take
some exception to that accusation which
is unfounded and has no evidence there
is no prospect whatsoever of a plan
officers of this Authority lying about
letters being issued to residents the
consultation that was undertaken there
was the correct consultation and the
applicant and again I'm choosing my
words carefully here the applicant noted
some concern raised about consultation
and again as all applicants are required
to do look to try and find ways to
address those issues and the ward member
will be aware of an invitation that has
been issued to all town members to
discuss the process and the sequential
approach taken to the various sites in
this in this application it is not a
matter for the application itself what
sites have been discounted but the
planning committee must consider the
application before it when it comes to
reconsider it and that is to consider
the site that is put forward however it
is legitimate that having had that issue
addressed the applicant can and will
seek to engage with ward members and I
would hope that the ward member will be
able to participate and attend Thank You
councillor Pemberton councillor
francelli thank you for the meeting
that's been called and I have actually
accepted that and I look forward to it
my concern is that this is on planning
grants and inappropriate site I
understand all that you've said about
looking at other sites this doesn't seem
the best place to put it and what
concerns me in a way and perhaps this is
good for the urgent meeting is this
planning application seem to have come
so long after the gift was was given and
there was no real understanding among
councilors as as to the gift I I am I
think counselor John said at the meeting
she was she was unaware of it I'm
unaware I'm talk to other councillors
who were unaware of it and I do think
that the we can learn lessons from the
process like this that we should perhaps
be looking at something as important and
sensitive
pavilion earlier on in the process so
issues like this could have been
discussed and resolved at an earlier
date we've left ourselves with so little
time now to make the solutions that I
think we ought to be making come to
organ Thank You chairman I just want to
point out the sake of accuracy that on
the 15th of August in both the Stratford
Herald and The Observer there was the
article with photographs of the pavilion
and it was taken in the first garden and
it stated then that the proposed
location was to be the first garden and
that was in the local media in August
could I just make a comment there it's
not the best month to advertise it I
myself was on holiday at that time I
just think we've got some lessons to
learn eventually any councillor Ralph
you wish to speak
okay that I speak Chairman's discretion
you can speak thank you
I was alerted to this application in the
normal process very late in the day and
I was probably the one that pointed out
all the kind of thumb things that could
go wrong and would go wrong which then
led to the Clarisse officer objecting I
think the process is very flawed here
you know you could you can talk about
dates and going into papers and whatever
but something as prestigious as this the
district councillors for Stratford
didn't know anything about it didn't
know that it was going in the first
garden I'm sorry they didn't know it was
going in the first Belton I think the
consultation process is very flawed
there it's all very well putting up a
notice on the lampposts but a lot of the
residents were not aware that it was
going to be there
there there are two issues that I I have
and they are highways issues or one of
them to trees it came out in the
application on Wednesday night that
there will be more impact on the trees
and there will be more impact on those
trees and I think if you are going to
put again I'm on the cram Safety
Partnership since many times riding is
very important excuse me counselor Ralph
how does this actually fit into the
notice of motion I'm talking about
weather where the the thing is going to
go on the first garden it's it's the
what what you're doing here by putting
it there you are designing in crime you
are screening it with tall trees you are
designing in crime there is no place to
cross on that road it's very very unsafe
Council Fridays or do you mention that
and and the process of consultation was
flawed thank you
Thank You counselor Ralph can I just
point out we've already heard from
councillor Pemberton that the
consultation process was the standard
consultation process that all planning
applications go through sorry this now
is a meeting for cabinet members and
people invited to speak you are not
invited to speak please remain silent
I'm September - I think I just have to
repeat just an apologize if this starts
to sound repetitive that the yes the
applicant and this local planning
authority adhered to the requirements
that are laid down for advertising any
planning application and unless the
County Council board member is
suggesting that the notification she
received was late in which case I'm
somewhat surprised that she hasn't
raised that matter before as a matter of
failure of process then I will actually
take issue with the phrase late in the
day the County Council member had the
notification of the planning application
in the way that any County Council
member would have the notification of
any planning application that the
applicant and the planning authority
have adhered to the rules which are set
down not in this building but a set down
by government and through legislation
about how planning application
consultation should be conducted it is
an entirely different thing to make a
comment and it is a legitimate comment
to make that that consultation may or
may not have been could have been done
better that's a different thing entirely
but the notion that the process the due
process was not followed he's one that
is not something that I can accept as a
portfolio holder for planning because we
did follow the process
council organ Thank You chairman I'm
just coming back to the notice of motion
here because we tend to be drifting into
planning and whilst there are valid
planning reasons to be considered that
is not for the cabinet to do that is for
the planning committee to do the notice
of motion clearly requests cabinet to
examine possible alternative sites which
has already been done
I therefore recommend that the notice is
rejected before that council organ
councillor Morse as the person who
seconded the motion do you wish to speak
just to state accounts Morgan but if
this is no decided what is the point of
the meeting that's being held on
Wednesday to discuss other options it
seems to me that's a futile public
relations gesture we rather than
anything meaningful and Sherman I don't
want to get into an argument with
councilor organ because I think it's
important that we don't decide this on
political grounds that we do what's best
for the town can I just make one other
point too and that's the quote MCATs
around Perry from the Planning Committee
who raised what I thought was a very
very good point that she's been to China
on a number of occasions has seen
similar pavilions she says these things
are best viewed from a distance and that
struck me as a very sensible point this
is a large structure which will dominate
the landscape and it's best photographed
and viewed from a way away Jim and I
agree with entirely I can think of many
sites in the district of Newtown which
would meet that criteria but the first
garden most certainly doesn't thank you
Thank You councillor Morse councilor
organ has proposed if you could just
remind us council organ would you
propose the reason that already been
considered by Cabinet that motion is
rejected do I have a seconder for that
councilor Pemberton members of cabinet
can we vote on that please all those in
support of the motion I'm sorry in
support of the motion to reject to read
it okay that's unanimous thank you does
that mean the meeting to discuss this
other site on Wednesday is to be
counseled no no it does not and the
purpose of the meeting is is to outline
the background of the process of how the
first garden site has been arrived at
and that's part of that's part of a
that's part of the consultation and that
will be a discussion outlining how each
and every site that's been reviewed why
in it would not appear that those sites
can can work for the pavilion it's not
meant to be that there is a planning
application before this this counsel to
be considered and it's not the purpose
of that or this cabinet meeting to
undermine that I think the reality is
counselor laws we do not want to
undermine the planning processes for the
planning committee to decide but I think
it may well be worth given some of the
issues that were raised it may well be
worth exploring that those issues with
Town Council members and don't forget
many council members have had the
benefit of attending this meeting others
have not so moving on to item 5 on the
agenda I think a short break while
people who wish to leave leave would be
in order so we'll take a five-minute
recess
right meeting reconvenes and we move on
to item five revenue and capital budget
20 19 22 23 24 councillor all gonna
believe this is your earlier immense
expertise so over to you thank you
attached to the report of the draft
revenue and capital budgets for nineteen
twenty two twenty three twenty four
medium term financial forecast the draft
Capitol report is attached at appendix
five on page 103 and the new bids for
funding are shaded for ease of
identification the draft revenue budget
table is on page 39 again proposed
growth and savings are shown shaded and
the details of these are on page 54 the
budget assumptions for example pay
awards and contract increases are
itemized in paragraph 2.7 on page 27 the
funding streams are discussed in
paragraph 3 and tabulated on page 28 the
revenue support grant and completely
however the rural services delivery
grant remains for this year the major
source of income to the council new
homes bonus has been confirmed for the
next year however it is forecast to
reduce significantly over the medium
term the draft budget for the next year
is based on a council tax increase of
1.5% and shows a four thousand three
hundred and sixty four pound surplus
this budget aims to maintain a sound
financial structure for the future and
key objectives are kept are to keep
expenditure at sustainable levels within
available resources whilst making
realistic provision for inflation etc
and ensuring
early recognition of emerging issues the
budget process between now and the
council meeting on the 25th of February
will include consultation with the
public via the council's Sydney citizens
panel the council's overview and
scrutiny committee and local businesses
Thank You council organ chairman I'm not
going to go into great detail because as
you're aware detail I just wanted to
make a couple of broad points firstly
tents are all going to talks about
keeping expenditure at sustainable
levels well I wonder chairman how far
this is sustainable for residents we're
talking about a one and a half percent
increase here County Council's talking
about five percent the police are
talking about up to twenty four pounds
and of course we've got parish in town
increases on top of that chairman
that's very nearly a hundred pound a
year increase for AB and D thanks Beth
and clearly in the top top fans it's
going to be nearly double that for many
people that's very considerably more
than in the rate of inflation or the
rate at which their wages have gone up
so for many people chairman this is
going to be a far from sustainable
increase and I think to German residents
to be a bit surprised looking at this to
see that Wells borne costs the costs of
the world's borne action are going to be
put in the budget at one point one to
four million pounds Chairman nearly one
pound in every seven next year that this
council is raising through the council
facts it's planned to go on legal costs
for the world's on airfield again
chairman I think for many residents who
don't live around was gone that will
come as a bit of a shock that so much of
their money is going on this one action
one final point chairman is about
universal
revenue staffing costs are increasing by
ninety seven thousand pounds because of
delays in introducing universal credit
we can't get recruits because the
Housing Benefit system is closing down
after universal credit comes in and
people know that we've made five
attempts to recruit people to these
posts all of which you failed
I wonder chairman it's it's 97 thousand
pounds of a new staff or is it for
expensive agency staff because we can't
get stuff and one final point chairman
were saying in this report Universal
Credit can lead to revised bills every
month for the council tax reduction
scheme some residents have been getting
monthly letters changing their benefits
chairman this isn't cutter nonsense as
I'm sure you would agree thank you Thank
You councillor Morris I think why does
what you said about the overall increase
in council tax is correct the reality is
that the council tax increase for County
Council is a matter for the County
Council the council tax increase sorry
yes the precept for the police is a
matter for the police what we the thing
that we have control over is the precept
for the district and as my colleague
councillor organ said that is a
one-and-a-half percent increase which
compared to the other increases is low
it is not a huge amount and it is
necessary to keep our finances on the
sound footing they Wells borne airfield
provision is exactly that it is a
provision there will have to be reports
back to cabinet on the progress of
whatever happens under compulsory
purchase so we will keep a very very
close eye on it
I would say that the potential
compulsory purchase of wells borne earth
is a significant issue for the council
it preserves wells borne airfield as a
work in airfield which we committed to
in the core strategy it also preserves
industrial land of which there is a
significant shortage in this district it
is also to be fair councillor boss this
is something that I think would become
more and more aware of as we've gone
through this process that it is of some
strategic significance in the network of
airfields in the UK that is perhaps
something the government should consider
in terms of protection for airfields I
can't answer the questions directly on
the universal credit but perhaps my
colleagues code
mr. Platts thank you in relation to the
staffing costs if that's okay for me to
just take that point as well it's
actually something called civic or on
demand which is off-site processing so
it's slightly more expensive than
recruiting staff but less expensive than
agency stuff you will notice that there
is actually another advert in the herald
this week for to try and recruit
permanently so we continue to do that in
terms of universal credit we are making
an attempt to change the local council
tax reduction scheme in line with all
the Warwick sheera thora T's in 2020 to
try and address the very point that you
raised and quite clearly in the last
week we've had four changes to the
universal credit announcements as well
so we were aware of all those changes
that are coming on board
I wonder why we're plunging on spending
so much money checkup when the
government may well protect the airfield
anyway
at the moment there is a 16-week
consultation in process on that that
will not be over until April the
compulsory purchase process has a long
way to go at the moment we have not
spent a vast amount of money on it and
like I said earlier we will keep it
under review at cabinet slip em Burton
and we should think you wish to yes
thank you chair anything the question of
the potential of compulsory purchase of
wells born or Airfield has been
discussed by this council and has been
agreed even as a way forward by this
council and councillor Morse says that
he you know why should the council
taxpayers of this district fund 1.125
million pounds worth of legal costs that
and making the remark that the few of
the residents of wells ball might be
interested but it don't really affect
everybody else but the reality is that
the potential for Wells borne airfield
is far greater than the airfield itself
it is right to have the CPO process
running in tandem with anything that the
government might do to protect it
because the alternate I'm sorry you know
is are you seriously suggesting we just
give this up and then allow 1500 hours
is to be built in entirely the wrong
place at entirely the wrong time with no
benefit whatsoever for this district
other than to create traffic chaos and
allow the landowners and the developers
merely to make a profit we're about
making a difference to the residents of
this district all of the residents of
this district and that comes with a cost
sometimes and I for one am not really
minded just to say we'll give it up and
let it just become another house in a
state Thank You councillor Pemberton
anything else I would comment on the
overall figures that when you look at
them as as we go into the future through
to 23 24
business rate retention drops by one and
a half million pounds which is a
significant number and the new homes
bonus drops by three and a half million
that puts us under some very substantial
pressure over the next five years so I
think that just helps set the context of
the pressures we are facing with that
the recommendations are on page 25 there
are five recommendations these cabinet
happy with the recommendations thank you
moving on now to item 6 which is SDC
cash collection contract counselor braid
the process for procuring a new contract
the background to this agenda item is
the current cast collection contract
provided by g8 security was awarded in
November 2008 some 10 years ago for both
on-street and off-street parking pay
stations the on street parking services
were taken back in-house by Warwickshire
County Council in 2014 and the cash
collection contract was varied
accordingly subsequently the test
collection contact was expanded to
include collections from public toilet
paddle gates venture house the Visitor
Information Centre the contract includes
cash collection secure transportation of
attached cash secured cash canteen and
banking of cash the proposed procurement
process is outlined in dependencies one
to four and the cabinet has the option
to approve the procurement process
acetate above or the cabinet may propose
to an alternative process subject to
legal implications chairman or leader
rather the recommendations were tyring
submit to the cabinet are on page 1 1 2
4 though with the exclusion of the words
in the
recommendation for Bridgeway car park
parking management system should not be
in that recommendation some of its
delete bridge where car parks parking
management system yeah
Clyde help here leader try yes there's
been an error in the papers and the term
bridge way car park management system
should be am cash collection contract
any comments any discussion in that case
cabinet do you approve the
recommendations on page 109
recommendations one two for a grade
thank you cabinet item seven tenancy
access policy thank you
the summary for this policy is clear the
change has been brought about by
increased duties on the council by
legislation and this does dovetail into
other legislation driving policy for the
homeless and rough sleepers at present
is we're all aware our demand for access
outweighs supply high rents make it
difficult for vulnerable families to
access private rented property we have
new duties to prevent and relieve
homelessness and move from a reactive to
a proactive approach for which this
policy supports and adds another tool to
our toolkit by adopting this policy it
will also benefit us by reducing costs
which is the bed and breakfast bill that
we have just to make everyone aware it
will be evaluated in six months and a
formal report will be put to cabinet and
I draw your attention that the options
are at 4.1 and 4.2 Thank You councillor
Harris councillor Morse Thank You
chairman Chu and I have one question but
first can I just say how alarming I find
some of these figures 24 I think tip the
tables quite concerning
the number of households registered for
home choice has been climbing steadily
for the last four years but in the
second line of table 5.4 we find a
number of households rehoused has been
steadily dropping and we're at the
lowest point for four years in terms of
numbers as Chancellor Harris point out
from bed and breakfast cost the last two
years over half a million pounds gross
on on bed and breakfast but German my
question relates to five point two um
homelessness claims the number of people
coming forward claiming to be homeless
has steadily increased over the last
three years but the percentage of the
total who we've accepted as homeless
seems to significantly dropped and I
wondered why it is that all of a sudden
people who previously possibly would
have been regarded as homeless are no
longer classed as homeless I believe the
definition of homelessness has changed
but perhaps mr. weeks you could give a
far more thorough response than I Kevin
as always in the world of housing and
homelessness the picture is complex and
I really wouldn't like to answer Peter
Moses question with a simple oh it's
because the legislation has changed yes
it has but there have been a lot of
other social and economic factors that
have been a play here so if it's if it's
okay with your chairman I'm happy to
provide Peter Moss with some more
comprehensive they're responsive outside
of the meeting which I'll happily share
with all of cabinet I think mr. Wiggs
that a much more detailed response will
be welcomed and she'll be circulated to
all cabinet members and of course
Chancellor Moss because you are
absolutely right it is a complex area
and we may as well try to understand the
landscape thoroughly would you be
comfortable with that councillor Morse
with that the recommendations on page
121 recommendations one and two are
coming it happy with those
recommendations thank you eight report
on stratford-on-avon district social
inclusion statement 2019 224 and funding
allocation councillor harris again Thank
You leader I'd like to point out for
this policy that it was thoroughly
reviewed by the overview and scrutiny
with her task and finish group that the
core options are at five point one to
five point three but on page one five
five can I just draw your attention to
the table there three point four about
the difference in amounts at priority
one the amount of 60,000 should actually
be reflected as 40,000 there is a 20,000
difference due to being short on the
priorities identified by OSA who
suggested that more money could be spent
on credit options for people but due to
numerous budget pressures some growth
bids could not be supported and
retaining and that could not be pushed
through and retained that spending on
the voluntary sector is still a
considerable commitment it was also
noted that maybe the portfolio holders
should be involved in in the process but
the funding of the volunteer assists a
voluntary sector is agreed each year by
council when the budget is considered
and agreed so there has been no need for
the portfolio holder to be popped into
this policy or process and the only
other way that spending is agreed is
through contract which were reluctant to
get tied into for years to come
that's the only points I wanted to raise
today any comments questions from
covenant
can I just be clear counselor Henry sit
there is a recommendation three in there
about the involvement of the portfolio
holder in decision-making
no as I've just covered leader that
there was no need because this goes
before Council on the budget requests
each year and I understand with the
process there's no need for a portfolio
holder to be involved in the process in
that case our cabinet members happy with
the recommendations on page 153 agreed
thank you cabinets moving on now to item
nine Knapton on the hill neighborhood
plan Neighborhood Development Plan pre
submission consultation responses
councillor Pemberton Thank You leader so
this is the Knapton on the hill
Neighborhood Development Plan the
District Council approved nap table on
the hill as an area for formal
designation for a Neighborhood
Development parent back in July of 2017
the Neighborhood Development Plan Group
has undertaken some excellent work in
conjunction with members of the local
community and with offices in the policy
team chair and leader I can't see
anybody to to speak on this particular
one I'm not aware of any members pushing
to so I'm really going to say that we
move straight to the restaurants
recommendation as this is our pre
submission response the schedule of
significant comments is set out in the
appendix one minor comments for type of
typographical and presentational matters
are a separate appendix and seeking
members recommendation to accept this as
our formal response to the draft
thank you councillor Pemberton in that
case cabinet are we prepared to accept
the recommendation
on page 187 great thank you
item 10 this is the luxury neighborhood
development plan councillor Pemberton
again thank you leader chair and and
just checking again I don't see anybody
for for Loxley to speak on on this
matter again we are at the position of
the pre consultation responses however I
do want to place on record thanks for
the work that's been done by the
Neighborhood Development Plan group in
Loxley working with their their local
community and with our officers the
significant scheduler comments are at
Appendix 1 and the absence of any
questions comments move to a
recommendation to accept those Thank You
councillor Pemberton so members of
cabinet happy with a recommendation on
page 201 a great thank you members of
cabinet in that case we move on to item
11 parking standards a revised approach
and it's councillor Pemberton yet again
thank thank you leader the report before
cabinet's seeks to review and endorse
the revised approach that it is proposed
to take and to include in the
development requirements supplementary
planning document for parking
this sets out in essence a two-tier
approach based on zones
in essence a zone drawn around a tight
area of the town of stratford-upon-avon
and a second zone that in essence covers
everywhere else in the district there is
a need to ensure that we have the
revised parking standards SPD up and
running as soon as possible it gives
guidance and clarity members will be
aware that there has been debate as to
whether there should be any further
zoning within the district but that
really is a matter that needs some
further working up
happy to take any questions I also have
one of our policy officers Joe with us
to help any queries but the
recommendation is that the the to zone
approach which is outlined at appendix
three is adopted Thank You counselor
organ Thank You chairman
well I welcome this document and I think
that too it's it's time we ensured that
there is adequate parking on new
developments to avoid the situation that
we so often see and that the erosion of
that parking provision is also protected
is is I think of great importance to us
here in Stratford thank you Thank You
councillor organ any more questions of
debate councillor mores I should have
known
Thank You chairman Shimla I welcome this
proportion in particular the fact that
the offices of clearly listened to the
comments that came forward about
Stratford town itself and the changes
standards there and also that this is no
guidance rather than mandatory that's
very welcome just a couple of points you
when I am still concerned that cinemas
require new cinemas require one space
for every three seats which seems boniva
endure to render cinemas completely
impractical you'd have to be instructed
to build a brand new car park
effectively but I had a question
chairman which does changing change of
use equal development if a shop in the
center of town has a major change of use
for car parking purposes would that be
included under the development the
development so the answers yes and I
note your point about cinemas and I note
also your point that this is guidance
with that I also welcome these parking
standards I think it may well stop an
issue that we have particularly in
Stratford town but I know from comments
your mother
been rural centers that is it is not
Stratford town alone but has a issues
with parking so this will stop things
getting worse which i think is really
important with that the recommendation
on page 2 1 1 our cabinet members happy
with the recommendation thank you
cabinets moving on now to item 12 the
response to Warwickshire County Council
minerals development plan pre submission
consultation 2018
it is councillor Pendleton again thank
thank you thank you leader members of
cabinet before you at Appendix 1 are the
draft officer representations on the
County Council's
minerals development plan which is in
its pre submission consultation phase so
members are seeking endorsement and
during discussion of this item I've had
representations around policy s for the
allocation of site number 4 at was
'putin which does not seek to challenge
the site as such however it does seek
that our response is more robust in
terms of traffic management in and
around the what's button site to ensure
that there is no detriment no
unnecessary detrimental impacts on on
residents it also does request that it's
noted that was what that it is
unfortunate that was button has been
included although there are there appear
to be no grounds to challenge what's
button per se I am minded in conjunction
with officers to to discuss a tweak to
the wording to bolster members if you I
will draw you to page two one two five
one four two two five one policy s for
the final sentence says that the
district cancer will expect Lorie
movements to be strictly controlled so
that this does not happen it talks in in
terms of law
using site using minor roads I would be
looking for with cabinets forebearance a
little bit of latitude to discuss in
conjunction with officers just
strengthening that word in a little to
make it clear that we're we're looking
for an active strategy to ensure that
traffic movements are are monitored so
with that in mind and seeking your
approval to the remainder of the draft
and solo for me in conjunction with the
officer just to tweak that finally an
email from mr. Hobart field you see on
the wasp resident yeah I just say that I
completely concur with this report in
the draft one of the sites that was
promoting promoted was in my ward that
was taken out now I just want to for the
record say it's not just because it was
in my ward and it wasn't in my back
garden it wasn't bad at all there's a
poor sqeeze a bad site to being forward
and I'm glad that County saw sense in
that one and after the work very hard
work but county councillor council brain
it was removed so I just like to commend
this report thank you so looking at the
recommendation subject to what councilor
Pemberton has said that he would wish to
tweak in conjunction with officers
policy s for allocation at site for wasp
Burton our cabinet members happy with
that a great thank you cabinet
moving on item 13 sports facility
strategy 2016 to 2035 I don't think I'll
be using the sports facilities in 2035
however councilor Pemberton and
councillor Harris
Thank You leader I'll try and talk
deeper basically this summary says it
all and speaks about the document and
I'll just draw your attention to the
options on page two five four is option
one to endorse the recommendations of
the supports facility strategy as
presented and receive the document as a
technical report and evidence based
document an option two to reject the
recommendations of the supports facility
strategy and not accept the document as
a technical report and evidence based
document Thank You councillor Harris any
comments or questions from Cabinet no in
that case the recommendation on the page
253 is not accepted rade thank you
cabinet we now move on to agenda item 14
stratford-on-avon district air quality
technical planning guide this December
2018 councilors pemberton and Harris
again thank you leader normal service
now resumed members this is a piece of
technical evidence around the guidance
that this Authority should use in terms
of ensuring that air quality is
maintained we have two specific air
quality management areas in the district
one in the town was designated in 2010
and one incidentally in 2006 this is
there is no that there is nothing that
changes our approach will takes out
anything in terms of how we are seeking
to ensure that air quality is maintained
and improved so really this is a
straightforward accept or reject the
planning technical guidance in Appendix
1 to be used to inform plan making and I
would urge members to accept the
recommendation to accept the guidance
councilor Harris well it's appropriate
to say today but I will be having a
conversation with my colleague here and
two perks regarding the new national
changes and implementation that's on
their eyes and it's announced today
especially about enforcement Thank You
counsel Harris councilor organ Thank You
chairman
I am read in the newspapers recently in
local media that there were concerns
expressed there about the air quality
especially in the town here in Stratford
and I am very reassured that in actual
fact the fears that were expressed don't
seem to be well-founded at all thank you
thank you
cabinet can I have your agreement to the
recommendation on page two five nine
please thank you
agenda item 15 capital budget monitoring
councilor organ Thank You chairman this
report is the council's capital budget
for the first eight months up to the
30th of November the total planned
capital expenditure for the year ending
March is just a tad over six million
pounds and progress of the projects is
detailed in Appendix 1 an appendix to on
page 303 gives details of the section
106 payments held by this council with
their current status thank you any
questions discussion I believe not can I
have cabinets agreement to the
recommendation on page two nine five
please thank you
moving on to agenda item 16 revenue your
budget monitoring counselor organ again
thank you chairman again again this is
the same period the first eight months
up to the end of November and it shows
the variance for the period along with
the forecast out turn variance the
variance for the period is two hundred
and eighty two thousand pounds and the
out turn forecast for the year is two
hundred and twenty three thousand pound
the significant reasons for these
variances are detailed in power of four
of the report and illustrated within the
first attach the report thank you can
you we do have some of Andres we just
paid annually on some of our marriage
funds so I will check to see whether is
your call works better the year-end on
those investments thank you mr. Buckland
with that are there any more questions
in that case the recommendation on page
307 are coming at happy with that
Thank You Toby
moving on to Part C issues arising from
ons non cabinet work program to note the
cabinet work program that was circulated
and receive minutes from strategic
policy advisory group ages three one
nine two three to four and
stratford-upon-avon markets forum three
to five
3:30 our cabinet happy to receive those
papers
great thank you cabinets and with that I
declare the meeting closed
I'll take that as a no so I'm now
meeting players